the NFL has a conference call later
today in place of the annual league
meeting Chris we'd be in Florida today
if the world had indeed upside down
getting ready for more coverage of votes
and interview and coaches GM's and
owners today they are having a
conference call among all the owners and
among other things they're going to vote
on changes to the playoffs where there
is going to be unless they don't get
enough votes for it I think they will
get the votes for it to extra teams one
per conference only one team gets up by
the top seed in the AFC the top seed in
the NFC if 24 or more teams vote in
favor of it it will happen in 2020 where
there will be expanded playoffs and
reportedly CBS and NBC picking up extra
playoff games potentially if that's what
happens so that's happening today it'll
give us something to react to tomorrow I
still know how I feel about it because
that buy is so valuable that we're gonna
have one seed versus one seed in every
Super Bowl and I don't really like that
yeah I like more playoff football yeah
but I'm with you that does scare me I
mean it just it swings the pendulum more
in the favor of the one seed now I do
like you know that it makes them regular
season a little more competitive that
way but I think it's a little much and
also hey Mike you know I'm with you I
want more football too I love that but
it's you know scary to me you know again
I used Pittsburgh Steelers is the
perfect example this year you know were
they a PI off team they couldn't even
beat the backups of the Baltimore Ravens
in a game they had to win did we really
want to see duck you know duck Hodges
and and Mason Rudolph and a PI off game
and then maybe that defense hurts
Patrick mahomes you know somewhere down
the line maybe patch mom sprains his
ankle because bud Dupree falls on it and
then the playoffs are ruined and they're
not the same and the number once he does
go to the Super Bowl that's what I worry
about yeah and I think what will happen
is if the 1 seed versus 1 seed Super
Bowl occurs four or five years in a row
there will be a groundswell more from
the media and the fans so just go ahead
and get rid of all the buys and make it
a 16 team field and the owners attitude
will be well if you insist and we'll
have more playoff games we'll gladly
make more money and we'll give you what
you want but I'd rather forget the half
measure
if you're gonna get rid of one by get
rid of both byes and make the 1-seed
play as well I know that's another can
of worms Chris yeah the eight seed and
the eight seed isn't worthy either but
at least make the one seat play that
extra game yeah no I hear that but yet
then what's the reward for the season I
don't know you know and again to the
owners meeting they got to figure out
the coal but 19 response I'm still just
is the season gonna happen there we
gonna get all the games in I don't know
I mean there's just so many things
farewell NBC sports radio see you
tomorrow and NBCSN as good
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports